hello my name is the Stevens Reagan and
here from Brazil and a pleasure to be
here sharing some of our data in this
terrible event so here we are working
really Janeiro with IPS cells and that
we are using those cells for different
projects the lab is more known for the
work with the Zika virus and use it this
kind of approach with induced
pluripotent stem cells and their citizen
brain organoids to try to to see try to
understand how the virus infected the
developing brain tissue but besides this
approach we are also very interested to
use these cells to understand other
phenomena associated with brain function
our lab I'm showing now in this slide
some of our collaborate collaborate in
this in this project and on other
projects of the lab and also the
sponsors of the work that we are doing
in in Brazil
as I mention we are very interested to
understand how the brain works and to do
that we use IPS cells in this slide you
are seeing near themselves derived from
IPS cells and this is our main source of
cells that we use to differentiate them
in different cell types observe it and
present in the brain this is one way
that we believe it's important to
complement some of the work that is done
using port bottom brain tissue and mouse
models they were imaging another
approach so when you differentiate new
rooms or astrocytes or nerves themselves
from 90s cells we have a very
interesting to to work with the with
models of the brain and it become much
more interesting after this the very
important work of a chenille Yamanaka
reprogramming cells or creating two
reporters themselves from for example
fibroblast
in the lab besides using this induces
reporters themselves that are become
paralyzed we also use shelves
that would be obtained from the urine of
patients so because of this approach we
were able to obtain cells from patients
very few patients for example with
ultimate disease or mental disorders or
patients with this is associated with
development and we have now been with
ourselves from different kind of mental
disorders and these cells are available
for scientists interested to work in the
field so I really welcome all the
scientists that are interested to use
iPS cells derive different patients with
some mental and under illogical
disorders that are available in our
class so with this kind of tools right
like a human nerves themselves as the
sides and neurons we are working with
different
questions to try to understand and to
try to explain that happens in the in
the brain and we are also working with
brain organoids it's a very interesting
way to culture industry for the stem
cells and to understand and to stir a
little bit better some of the effects of
the network of cells within the the
brain one thing that is very interesting
and for me and for other guys which also
become a very a challenge it's kind of a
question to study and a very exciting
kind of a challenge I would say please
be work with the psychedelics like if
you see in this light until the
seventies there was a pretty interesting
amount of studies about the potential
author of ethical potential of some of
the psychedelic compounds then because
of the war on drugs and other questions
for the profession especially there was
a very decrease in the number of studies
using psychedelics and now more recently
like in the last 10 years there was what
we call psychedelic a renaissance in the
sciences as a because of different
scientists in for example Europe in the
US and also in Brazil they are starting
to study again these compounds in Brazil
we study different compound different
psychedelic compounds but especially one
that is associated with some of the our
culture environment and one of these one
of those compounds came from one picture
we call ayahuasca the a vodka is being
used for for several years from the
shamanic II and Indian populations in
the country and awesome whole South
America and recently some scientists
from the North East of the view
especially
all usual and sidarthur bill they are
testing the potential of ayahuasca as a
plant depressant drug more specifically
the compounds that are present in this
ayahuasca
that's associated with us some religions
in Brazil for example sometime a bikini
and the UDV are examples of these
religions that are developed in the
forest areas of the our country
and when you look at this ayahuasca
compound it's a mixture mixture of two
different plants and and it's able to
it's possible to identify the main
compounds present in this diction
mixture so in this slide you are seeing
an example of compounds present in
ayahuasca one of them is called carmine
in the other is called the YouTube
tryptamine or DMT that kids can be
present in two different forms and
ambien tea and five male games any
Indian tea is the mainly DMT present in
the in the ayahuasca compound
and they are they have this kind of
allison agenda key characteristic right
so they are molecules that involve it in
outer states of consciousness such as
dreams magical imagination insightful
creativity so this is what believed that
they did how DMT help and create this
psychedelic effects in the brain but our
mind seems very important for this DMT
is to reach the brain because during the
rituals the people did they drink this
thing this picture that we call the
gouache and then if there there was no
our mind in this lecture the DMT was
going to be inactivated by the liver
monoamine oxidase the enzyme right and
then the effect was not be or didn't he
was not able to reach the brain we're
not causing the defect so this was the
mainly believe it
role of our mind in this mixture but we
decided to see if our mind to be able to
have any direct effect in the brain or
yourselves from the brain so in order to
do that we started testing the effect of
our mind in nerves themselves derived
from IPS cells
in this light you are seeing the
approach that it uses the workflow that
you use it for these four steps so
basically we play the D there themselves
and then we expose them to our mind and
after different period of times we
tested for for proliferation creating
perforations of ability differentiation
etc and what we we thought it was
interesting is that there is increase in
the number of proliferating cells the
number of nurse themselves after the
exposure to our mine what it's
interesting and not only the
depreciation of this nest themselves but
also from Radio glial cells and this for
us was a very interesting result these
are mine was not able to cause DNA
damage or cell death in our cultures but
also is something important to be
studied
your mind is able to eat the monoamine
oxidase but also another enzyme called
the x1 a so we decided to test which
should be the preferential pathway on
how our mind would include proliferation
in this layers themselves
so we compare the effect of our mind
with two other compounds one it's a well
known behavior of DNA and the other is
inhibitor of monoamine oxidase and what
we saw is that there are mine mediated
addition of the UN a is probably in
mechanism or this signaling pathway that
increases neurogenesis indeed
this work was published and because of
this first work we decided to explore
other compounds present in the not only
in ayahuasca but also in other
psychedelic substances what was
interesting also for us because of this
result is the fact that big were not
this kind it is also associated with
Down syndrome and with it and is also
considered as a risk factor for of
diamond disease moreover it was
published recently also that D :
increases the proliferation of human
from reactive beta cells so we believe
that the very interesting biology the
study of our mind but let's return to
the other compounds present in the these
psychedelics as I mentioned to you in
the beginning of the presentation DMT
and this compound with this house
energetic e effect and the psychedelic
effect in the brain so and you have this
DMT in two forms one is any and empty
and the other is v my identity we
decided to expose ourselves to 5 million
T that's present mainly in this
so associated with some realistic
ritualistic Kirito ritualistic
manifestations in the mexico fraction
so we expose our nerves themselves to
five males empty and we did not find any
result or in other words we didn't find
any change in proliferation of those
cells when they are isolated in the in
vitro but we observe it also that like
this helps in this stage of development
they don't have the set of the MLC
receptors and you can see here this
result in share in the in the letter A
in this graph in this slide so they have
the signal one receptor but they don't
have the certain LC receptor that they
are activated by TMT so we move it to
move on to another model right that I
also introduced it in in the in my
presentations that these are the human
brain organized and we before we dig the
experiment we confirm that like these
cells within the brain organized they
have the five male the signal receptor
and also the the shelter and SQS centers
as we can see in Figure H so we expose
this brain organized to DMT and after 24
hours we did and we prepare the material
to do proteomics shotgun proteomics and
it was a very interesting approach we
did it in collaboration with other
colleagues from initiates from San Paolo
Daniel Martinez and others and it is a
very elegant approach to see what would
be the change present in the tissue
after being exposed to DMT we published
this paper and everything in the product
was an honor to say that like this paper
became one of the top 100 actual to us
because among top 25 papers publishing
in this journal last year among 25 tons
of papers the forest was very
interesting contribution to to the
psychedelic science
and what we saw with this date first we
were able to identify several proteins I
was 100 proteins change it by the
exposure by 21 cells in the human brains
they were human brain organoids they
were exported to to DMT right and more
than 300 of them were downregulated and
almost 600 were upregulated and with
this information in hand and with the
collaboration of the trade off from our
colleagues we decided to see using some
algorithms and softwares
what would be the pathways change it by
the within yourselves when exposed it
will be empty so in this in this slide
you are saying the for example in
addition of inflammation in the neuro
tissue when the cells are exposed to
five male Dimity we also observed that
like pathways so sated with their
degeneration and so that they are also
inhibited by pres neo DMT which we
believe is interesting as a to be
explored as a rotation triple key
effects of the substance so the goal of
this work was basically to highlight and
to identify pathways change it by DMT in
the brain tissue
sighs this change we also deserve it a
reorganization of cytoskeletal and
changing the dendritic spine
we also observed that like the long-term
potentiation components are modulated by
five mil entity which would suggest that
like some mechanisms associated with
plasticity could be altered by DMT
highlighting the importance twisted
psychedelics will be with the potential
to become new drugs to treat for example
depression so what we basically did was
to try to explore the cellar and macrame
and molecular aspects of this
psychedelic and to contribute with the
other studies that are applying it in
for example in the context of the
ayahuasca for depression for depression
in patients so we believe that our
contribution could help to better design
new clinical trials using for example
our mine or DMT
so this is slide basically summarize
what I show to you that would be one
possible we effect of our mind in the
region is we of course observe it
getting vehicle but we believe and there
are other colleagues trying to explore
this aspect especially in this case in
vivo another collector doing that to
explore the potential of our mind
inducing new regimes and because of the
already described effect of ayahuasca in
depression we believe that maybe this is
the molecular explanation for that and
the other compound that we studied in
this that church even this presentation
DMT which as I mentioned to you is
associated to this in our model in these
signaling pathways that are connected
for example with brain plasticity and
with their inflammation
in summary we show that like our mind
enhance knowledge and indeed for the
division of the ik 1a we also saw that
that is that show that there is a change
in the global protein expression after
exposure to fight me on Mt
and we highlighted changes in the
anti-inflammatory single pathway and
also proteins involved with learning and
memory and we also observe it the
regulation of the M glue r5 after the
exposure of five-day identity and the
traps interesting since there are also
some student scientists working on the
potential of five new identity as a way
to treat drug abuse and finally we
observed that there is some cell death
pathway inhibit
by five million T so there are
interesting biology and potential
therapeutic in approach or applications
for psychedelics and this just examples
of two of them that we are studying
using induces reproduce themselves they
were serious brain organized and the
cell types that were able to raise in
our cultures thank you very much for
your attention and it is my pleasure to
work with durable and to share with you
the kind of work that we developed here
in Brazil specially in Rio de Janeiro in
the door institute for research and
education and also at the federal versus
of revision in in this slide you have
the website from our Institute and also
the website from my lab thank you very
much